Did you stay up late to study?
That's so unlike you.
I was thinking about my life.
-Morning!
-Hey.
-Morning.
-Morning!
What is it?
What's going on?
-Hinode?
-What is it?
This is for you!
-What?
TO KENTO HINODE
Is that a letter I see, Miss Muge?
It's none of your business!
Is it a love letter?
-Give it back!
-Niibori!
-Got it!
-Muge!
Miss Muge, Miss Muge! Over here!
-Confession time!
-Knock it off!
How about I read it out loud?
Ta-da!
-Cut it out, you two!
-Are you really going to read it, Bannai?
She went all out! How pathetic can you be?
"To Hinode.
I feel happy whenever I see you."
-Bannai!
-"Hinode Sunrise isn't just a pun."
Give it back!
"It's how I feel about you.
You're my sunrise."
-The letter isn't for you!
-Give it back!
-"Hinode Sunrise is
when the sun rises above the horizon
-and warms my soul."
-Stop it!
Give it back!
Why are you so desperate?
Is this too embarrassing for you?
Why should I be embarrassed?
Don't make fun of my feelings!
Are you going to accept
her love confession?
Mr. Sunrise?
Hinode...
What?
Why?
Confession time! Confession!
Shut up!
I just wanted you to cheer up.
I'm just like you.
I can't say the things I truly feel.
-So--
-I'm not like you!
This is embarrassing for me.
Have you considered my feelings?
He read it in front of everyone.
I hate pushy people like you.
But... what if I told you
in person instead--
Just leave me alone!
Didn't you hear me? I hate you!
You hate me?
I really hate you.
I see.
You hate me that much, huh?
Muge?
That's too bad.
Muge!
Die!